aquí tengo un número escrito tiene un
dos o un tres y un cinco y ya tenemos
algo de experiencia con números así
pensemos en lo que representa y para
pensar en esto tenemos que ubicar los
valores por posición el lugar más a la
derecha representa las unidades así que
este 5 representa 5 unidades este 3 está
en el lugar de las decenas tenemos tres
decenas por lo que va a ser 30 y este 2
está en el lugar de las centenas
este 2 aquí significa que tenemos 200
este número podemos verlo como 235 o
como 200 más 30 más 5 lo que quiero
hacer en este vídeo es ver los lugares
de valor a la derecha del lugar de las
unidades y me pueden decir oye espera yo
pensé que las unidades estaban en el
lugar más hacia la derecha y en efecto
todo lo que hemos hecho hasta este
momento ha sido así pero para mostrar
que podemos ir más hacia la derecha voy
a poner un punto aquí ya esto lo
llamamos punto decimal y este punto
significa que todo lo que se encuentre a
la derecha de este serán lugares de
valor más pequeños que la unidad si nos
vamos a la izquierda de este punto
tenemos las unidades las escenas las
centenas y si seguimos esta era el lugar
de los miles pero si nos vamos a la
derecha del punto decimal vamos a
dividir entre 10 cada vez a qué me
refiero bueno justo a la derecha del
punto decimal vamos a tener el lugar de
las décimas
qué significa esto pues cualquier número
que escriba yo aquí nos va a decir
cuantas décimas tenemos aquí
si yo escribiera el número cuatro mi
número ahora sería doscientos más
treinta más cinco más cinco unidades más
cuatro décimas lo podemos representar
como cuatro por uno entre diez
o podemos escribir cuatro décimas no
decenas décimas
cuatro décimas es lo mismo que esto 4
entre 10
esta es una idea importante en
matemáticas ahora puedo usar mis lugares
de valor para representar fracciones
este punto cuatro son cuatro décimas
otra forma de escribir este número es
y cuatro décimas así que lo puedo
escribir así como un número mixto esto
de aquí es una representación decimal
230 y 5.4 esta es una representación
usando números mixtos 235 4 decimos pero
ambos son 200 más 30 más 5 más 4 decimos
veamos algunos ejemplos más de esto
digamos que quiero analizar el número
0.7 y quiero llegar un lugar más a la
derecha 0.76 que representa esto si lo
escribiera como fracción analicemos los
lugares de valor tenemos nuestro punto
decimal a la izquierda de este punto
está el lugar de las unidades pero aquí
tengo 100 unidades ahora tengo 7 décimas
este es el lugar de las décimas y este
lugar a la derecha de este vamos a
dividir entre 10 nuevamente así que será
el lugar de las centésimas
así que este lo podemos escribir como
cero unidades más siete décimas
nuevamente no son decenas son décimas
más seis centésimas seis centésimas no
centenas centésimas
o podemos escribir esto como cero más
siete décimas más seis centésimas seis
sobre 100 este 0 7 décimas más 6
centésimas es lo mismo que éste 0.76
podemos llamar a este número cero
unidades siete décimas seis centésimas
otra forma es escribir esto como una
sola fracción aquí puedo ignorar este
cero no me va a modificar el valor y
hago la suma de estas dos fracciones
cómo puedo escribir siete décimos en
términos de centésimos bueno 7 sobre 10
es lo mismo que 70 sobre 100 una forma
de verlo es que si multiplicó el
denominador por 10 y el numerador
también por 10 no cambio el valor aquí
voy a tener 70 sobre 100 y ahora si
puedo sumar estas 70 centésimas con
estas seis centésimas que es lo que nos
va a dar pues va a ser 76 centésimos así
que este número de aquí muchas personas
lo llamarán 0.76 y también lo pueden
llamar 76 centésimas ese es el lugar de
las centésimas este es el lugar de las
décimas pero cada décima vale 10
centésimas y esto lo podemos ver como
siete décimas o como setenta centésimas
así que son 76 centésimas y podemos
continuar más hacia la derecha si
fuéramos un lugar más a la derecha
tendríamos el lugar de las milésimas y
otro más a la derecha sería el lugar de
las diez milésimas cada vez que nos
movemos a la derecha dividimos entre
diez cada vez y multiplicamos por diez
cada vez que nos movemos hacia la
izquierda